in this course you'll be using Google
Chrome and Chrome's developer tools
which we call dev tools for short if you
haven't used chrome dev tools before
check out the link in the instructor
notes for some information and
instructions for getting started you can
use dev tools to quickly get an idea of
how your site performs on a range of
different devices however emulators and
simulators can never really replace the
experience of using a real phone or
tablet to test your work on a phone or
tablet you'll need to make sure that
you're set up to use remote debugging
for the remainder of this lesson you'll
be getting some instructions from Peter
lubbers on how to get started with
mobile dev tools and debugging on your
mobile devices if you're already
familiar with mobile debugging feel free
to skip ahead to the video called lesson
1 wrap-up